now let's get conspiratorial and have
some fun here there's no question in my
mind that there was ancient
civilizations and they were the one that
built all these monolithic structures
and this is the story of like a massive
flood that came across and like
destroyed everything you guys had a
version of it right did they all just
cook up the same myth or did something
happen and then they all wrote stories
about them Atlanta is actually in the
Sahara people are looking for Atlanta
some island in the middle of the ocean
but it was actually in the set yeah look
at this this to this day is what it
looks like apparently all the stones
from the Great Pyramid of Giza come from
like a 12-hour Drive Away you're
dragging it on wet sand 100 ton
perfectly yeah some wild [__] about this
thing the head of the Sphinx is really
small you don't just make the head small
by mistake what they're saying is
another civilization found the Sphinx
then carved their own face onto the
existing face and it was most likely a
dog this is my favorite podcast episode
we've ever done I knew none of this oh
dude I'm excited
thank you